HENRY SHACKLETON: I don't know.
I think Junior Lab was a
really great experience.
I like that it gave people room
to figure things out and come
up with their own ideas,
come up with their own ways
of proceeding with analysis.
For example, in my
first experiment which
was relativistic dynamics,
you take electrons,
you accelerate them
in magnetic fields
and measure the kinetic
energy which ultimately proves
relativity, there was
sort of this error
that I ran into which was a
very strange sort of error that
wasn't really well documented.
So I did a lot of
independent reading.
I talked with my lab professor
for like two hours after a lab.
And by the end, it really felt
like I had independently came
to like a very deep
conclusion on this matter.
It was a good experience of
sort of independent learning
and figuring things
out for yourself.